here are some pictures what most people
associate when they think of chemistry
they think of scientists working on a
bench with the different vials of
different chemicals they might think of
a mad scientist they some of them
boiling and changing colors they might
associate chemistry with chemical
equations thinking about how different
things will react together to form other
things they might think about models of
different molecules that can be depicted
different ways they might associate it
with the periodic table of elements and
all of these things are a big part of
chemistry but what I want you to do in
this video is appreciate what at its
essence chemistry is all about and
chemistry is one of the sciences that
really just helps us understand and make
models and make predictions about our
reality and even something like the
periodic table of elements which you'll
see at the front of any chemistry
classroom you take it for granted but
this is the product of frankly thousands
of years of human beings trying to get
to an understanding of all of the
different complexity in the world you
know if you look at the world around us
and it doesn't even have to be our
planet it could be the universe around
us you see all these different
substances that seem to be different in
certain ways you see things like fire
and rock and water even in the planets
you know you see meteorology illogical
patterns in life you see all of this
complexity and all of these different
things and it looks like there's just
like an infinite spectrum of different
nough sout they're of different
substances even things like our human
brain the complexity and the electro
chemical interactions and you could
imagine as a species it's kind of
overwhelming how do you make a sense of
all of this and it was not a it was not
an easy path but over thousands of years
we did start to make sense of it and why
it's very lucky for all of us to be born
when we are now or to be around when we
are now to be able to learn chemistry
where we all now is that we get the
answer and it's a partial answer which
is also exciting because we
want the full answer but it's a partial
answer that takes us a long way we
realize that the periodic table of
elements that all of this complexity
that we're seeing before that at the end
of the day things are made of basic
building blocks kind of you can imagine
you know the Legos that really make up
everything and there aren't an infinite
number of Legos there's actually a
finite number and we're discovering more
all of the time well not all of the time
now new elements are not discovered that
frequently but there's a few of these
elements that are disproportionately
showing up in a lot of what we see here
these things that seem so different well
a lot of this is different compositions
of elements like carbon and oxygen and
hydrogen and even the elements
themselves are made of things like
protons and electrons and neutrons that
are just rearranged in different ways to
give us these elements that have all of
these that have all of these different
properties so when you think about
chemistry yes it might have it might
visually look something like this he's
around to see much older pictures but at
its essence it's how do we create models
and understand the models that describe
a lot of the complexity in the universe
around us and just to put chemistry in I
guess you could say in context with some
of the other sciences many people would
say at the purest level you would have
mathematics that math you're studying
ideas even even which could even be
independent you're saying logical ideas
that could be even independent of
anything that you've ever observed or
experienced and a lot of folks that say
if we ever communicate with another
intelligent species that could be
completely different than us math might
be that common language because even if
we perceive the world differently and
think differently in certain ways Matt
might be that common language that on
top of math we start to say well how is
our reality actually structured at the
most basic level what are the
constituents of matter and what are the
mathematical properties that describe
how they react together and then or
interact with each other and then you go
one level above that
you get to the topic of this video which
is chemistry which is really which is
very closely related to physics when we
talk about these chemical equations and
we create these molecular structures the
interactions between these atoms these
are quantum mechanical interactions that
we art which we do not fully understand
at the deepest level yet but with
chemistry we can start to make use of
the math and the physics to start to
think about how all of these different
building blocks can interact to explain
all sorts of different phenomena what we
this chemical equation you see right
here this is combustion this is hydrogen
combusting with oxygen to produce a lot
of energy to produce energy and in the
photo you could and when we imagine
combustion we think of fire but what
even is fire at its at its most
fundamental level how do we get why do
we perceive this thing here and
chemistry is super important because on
top of that we build biology we build
biology and as you'll see as you study
all of these things there's points where
these things start to bleed together but
the biology and say a human being or
really in any species it's based on
molecular interactions interactions
between molecules between atoms which at
the end of the day is all about
chemistry as I speak the only reason why
I'm able to speak is because of really
hard to imagine a number of chemical
interactions happening in me right now
to create this soundness to create this
thing that thinks that exists that wants
to make a video about how awesome and
amazing chemistry is and then from
biology you can build out on all of
everything else so scientists like
psychology and economics which of course
these things also will leverage math and
other things but this gives you kind of
a a sense of how we build up and how we
explain the reality around us and not
not one of these is more important than
the other these are all studying
incredibly fascinating things that have
that as human beings first became
thoughtful about their environment said
gee why are we here what is this place
why do we exist how do we exist and
chemistry
he builds models for us to understand
interactions at a scale and a speed that
we can't directly observe but
nonetheless we can start to make
predictions so that's what's really cool
about this when you study chemistry you
should not view this as some type of a
chore that the school system is forcing
you through you are getting there are
people who would have done anything a
hundred years ago to get the answers
that are in your chemistry book today or
that you can learn from your chemistry
teacher or that you could learn from a
Khan Academy video there are people in
the world in the past and today who do
anything to be able to understand deeply
what this is they consider it a
privilege it's to be able to uh to learn
at this level and then to think about
where this could go
because none of these fields are
complete that we have very partial
knowledge of all of these fields
arguably there's there's an infinite
more that we can learn relative to what
we know but what's exciting is that we
have such a strong start we're starting
to make sense of it to really describe
everything in our reality